because for me when it comes to projects
and like bodies of work i really like to
take my time of course
live life a little right but i don't be
meaning to take like years
i really like to take my time but i feel
like what people don't realize is like
[ __ ] we go through [ __ ] too like life
happens yeah so
even though we don't intentionally
or at least i know i don't intentionally
mean to be
you know dropping albums at four-year
span or whatever just [ __ ] i'll be going
through [ __ ] hey and that [ __ ] that you
go through gives you more more content
to write about i don't be mad about the
[ __ ] that i go through because i'm like
any situation whether good or bad
especially bad situation i'm like yo
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] up but at the same
time it's gonna make for a good song
you know so i can't really be too mad
about the situation though i can't be
really too down on my luck because i
know it's gonna
it's gonna come out to be a great song
somewhere along the line